S
DIESEL FUEL.
FOR DETAILS ON THAT COMING UP IN
A MOMENT, BUT FIRST, JOINING US
NOW WITH REACTION OF THE
MISSOURI SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY.
SENATOR, WHY YOU HAD TO SAY TO
THEM AND REMIND THEM WHY CAN'T
THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY DID
ABANDON OUR FELLOW AMERICANS,
THEY ABANDONED HUNDREDS -- WE
DON'T HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER.
AT ONE POINT IN THE HEARING
TODAY ONE OF THE PEOPLE
TESTIFYING ACTUALLY SAID IT
COULD BE AS HIGH AS 4,000, I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY AMERICANS
WERE ABANDONED.
I CAN'T SAY.
THEN WE ABANDON GREEN CARD
HOLDERS, THEN WE ABANDONED THEIR
FAMILIES, AND WE ABANDONED OUR
AFGHAN ALLIES, ALL BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, AND IT'S 45 DAYS,
SENATOR.
YOU SEE A LOT OF HELP GETTING
THEM HOME?
>> NOT BASED ON WHAT I'M
HEARING, SEAN, ENTERS WITH THE
REAL REASON, WHY WON'T THEY
ADMIT IT, IT'S BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIVE BILL.
GENERAL MILLEY DOESN'T WANT AND
RESPONSIBLY, AUSTIN DOESN'T WANT
RESPONSIBILITY.
MOST OF ALL JOE BIDEN DOESN'T
WANT TO TAKE ANY RESPONSIBLY,
BUT IT'S TIME THAT THEY DID,
WHICH IS WHY ALL THOSE GUYS
SHOULD RESIGN.
MILLEY NEEDS TO RESIGN, AUSTIN
NEEDS TO RESIGN.
MILLEY, HE IS SITTING HERE
TRADING GOSSIP WITH BOB WOODWARD
WHILE AFGHANISTAN LITERALLY
BURNS ERIE LITERALLY BURNS.
THE ACCOUNT ABILITY HAS GOT TO
START RIGHT THERE.
HE NEEDS TO RESIGN, AUSTIN NEEDS
TO RESIGN, THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
FIRE THEM.
>> Sean: YOU SAID THAT TO
AUSTIN, DON'T ONLY WE ARE NOT
LEAVING AMERICANS BEHIND, WHY
DID YOU HAVE TO REMIND HIM OF
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST
EXTRAORDINARY THAT HE WOULD SIT
THERE UNTIL THE COMMITTEE --
BECAUSE WHAT HE SAID, SEAN, WAS
WE HAVEN'T LEFT AMERICANS
BEHIND.
HE SAID THAT, HE'S UNDER OATH
THAT HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IT'S A JOE BIDEN
TALKING POINT.
JOE BIDEN'S WHITE HOUSE IS SAID
WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY LEAVE
AMERICANS BEHIND.
GUESS WHAT?
WE ARE NOT IN AFGHANISTAN, THE
AMERICAN CIVILIANS SIGIL ARE,
MANY OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
STILL THERE, STILL TRAPPED, AND
THEY ARE DENYING IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS DENYING
IT.
IT IS JUST SHAMEFUL.
FOR THAT REASON ALONE, AUSTIN
AND REALLY OUGHT TO RESIGN.
IF >> Sean: DID WE EVER GET AN
ANSWER TO A PLAN TO TRY AND
RESCUE OUR FELLOW AMERICANS THAT
THEY ABANDONED?
IS THERE ANY PLAN IN PLACE TO
TRY TO GET THEM OUT?
BECAUSE THE LAST TIME I HEARD
FROM TONY BLINKEN, HE ACTUALLY
SAID, IF YOU HAVE A CHARTERED
FLIGHT WITH AMERICANS ON IT,
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO LAND IN
THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU GET A THIRD PARTY COUNTRY
TO ACCEPT HER CHARTER, THAT'S
FINE, BUT IF YOU NEED OUR
APPROVAL, IT WILL NOT BE
FORTHCOMING.
WHY WOULD WE ALLOW A PLANE
CHARTERED WITH AMERICAN CITIZENS
ON TO LAND IN AMERICA TO GET
THEM THE HELL OUT OF THAT HELL
HOLE OF AFGHANISTAN RUN BY
TERRORISTS?
>> I HAVE NO EARTHLY IDEA AND
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN
TERMS OF THEY ARE NOT BEING A
PLAN, IF THERE IS ONE I DIDN'T
HEAR ABOUT IT TODAY AND HERE'S
THE OTHER THING, SEAN.
WE ALSO LEARNED TODAY THE REASON
ALL OF THOSE AMERICANS, OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS, GOT LEFT
BEHIND, IS BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
WAITED TOO LONG TO ORDER AN
EVACUATION.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE GUTS TO ORDER
AN EVACUATION WHEN THEY NEEDED
TO BE ONE.
HE ALLOWED OUR MILITARY TO DRAW
DOWN TO ZERO WITH AMERICAN
CIVILIANS ALL STILL THERE AND
WHEN THEY NEEDED TO BE
EVACUATED, HE WOULDN'T DO IT, HE
WAS WORRIED ABOUT HOW IT WOULD
LOOK, AND NOW HERE WE ARE,
AMERICANS ARE LEFT BEHIND, HE
HAS ABANDONED THEM, 13 SHOULDERS
TO SOLDIER IS DEAD.
>> Sean: LET ME PUT UP ON THE
SCREEN, YOU WILL PROBABLY NOT BE
ABLE TO SEE IT.
IT'S A MAP OF AFGHANISTAN, ALL
THOSE RED SECTIONS, YOU CAN SEE
THE CORRESPONDING DATES, MAY,
JUNE, AND THE JULY AND JULY, BY
THE WAY, WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS
SAYING THAT THE MILITARY IS SOME
OF THE BEST TRAINED IN THE
WORLD, THEY HAD OVER DICKSTEIN
PERCENT OF THE COUNTRY, THEY'VE
BEEN ON THE MARCH FOR MONTHS,
AND EVERYBODY KNEW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
JOE NEVER FIRED A SINGLE DRONE
SHOT, NOR DID HE MOVE UP THE
DATE WHEN WE HAD CONTROL OF
KABUL TO SAFELY EVACUATE EVERY
AMERICAN FROM EVERGREEN
CARDHOLDER, EVERY FAMILY MEMBER
AND EVERY AFGHAN ALLEY AND IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF WE TOOK
OUR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SOPHISTICATED WEAPONRY WITH US
AS WELL, SENATOR.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHEN BIDEN SAYS STUFF LIKE
NOBODY SAW THIS COMING, THAT IS
SIMPLY FALSE.
YOU CAN LOOK RIGHT THERE.
THE FACTS THAT YOU PUT ON THE
SCREEN, THEY WERE ON MAJOR
OFFENSIVE IN EARLY SPRING, HIS
OWN GENERAL ON THE GROUND WARNED
BIDEN THAT THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT
WOULD FALL THEN GET BIDEN DID
NOTHING, HE DIDN'T ORDER AN
EVACUATION, HE DID GIVE AMERICAN
CITIZENS OUT, HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
GUTS TO DO IT WHEN HE SHOULD
HAVE DONE IT AND NOW, BECAUSE OF
THAT, WE HAVE AMERICANS --
>> Sean: SO BIDEN LIED AND
AMERICANS DIED.
FAIR